what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder this is going to be it's
it's not really the first podcast
because i've done this a few times but
this is the first
one in the new go at it then this one's
going to be around for a while so of
course uh the guess of the first one is
chris i think everybody knows chris if
you don't know chris panel host over at
cosmic culture we'll put that link in
the description down below and of course
he works at the cosmic wonder as well
part of the cosmic crew him and his wife
ally cat at marvel minute news and
we were both at the world premiere of
doctor strange and multiverse of madness
and just watched it again
so we're here to do our spoiler review
we did a spoiler free one but if you
have not seen the movie this is your
spoiler warning we will be talking about
spoilers for doctor strange in the
multiverse of
madness now chris have you rated it yet
have you publicly rated it yet i haven't
publicly rated it now i don't even know
if i've personally managed to rate it
yet because i do go back and forth
with certain elements you know i mean
you've done what movie reviews for
almost five years now you know there's a
lot of different elements like you could
really like one thing or really like
something different
i definitely have a high rating waiting
for it something really high like i'm
thinking like eight maybe even nine
okay but i still don't know that maybe
by the time we're done chatting about it
here i'll have a
a better idea we'll we'll hash it out
here to see the true rating
that doctor strange two deserves i
personally
i really enjoyed it and i i don't enjoy
the creepy horror type of vibe stuff um
so right off the bat if anybody's you
know
well i'm assuming if you're watching
this you've seen it
right or you just don't care about
spoilers so yeah you know the creepiness
to it um as it is i want to know if you
guys thought that was
appropriate not appropriate that's
probably not the right word but if it
worked for marvel
marvel movie i don't even think that
that's the wrong word and here's why you
know marvel has
this set of expectations from its
audience parents who rely on marvel who
have kids dress up as spider-man you
know here it is kind of out of like not
everybody's on youtube every day
listening to what the cosmic wonder has
to say to know that this might have
these
horrific scenes and like we want to talk
about let's just jump right into it the
illuminati and them just getting
not even destroyed pummeled
pulverized
and yeah
in horrible ways some parents might not
actually
have been ready for that oh here's
another marvel movie my kid loves marvel
they dress up as x character let's take
him to the marvel movie and the next
thing you know
you know
those were some some scenes
and thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video as we all know
life can get pretty hectic sometimes and
it's pretty easy to feel overwhelmed and
anxiety whether it's work school family
or relationships sometimes you just want
somebody to talk to that's where better
help comes in if you feel like you need
somebody to talk to or you just need to
check up on your mental health better
help is an online resource that allows
you to do just that connecting with a
therapist online from the comfort of
your home they have a broad range of
officially licensed therapists over 20
000 therapists in their network which
makes it very convenient to find a
therapist that works for you and you can
change therapists at any time for free i
know it can be a lot easier to receive
therapy from the comfort of your own
environment and it's not just therapy
sessions you can message your therapist
at any time check out some information
that may be useful to you and schedule
your appointments all from the same page
head to betterhelp.com
cosmic to answer a few questions and get
paired up with a therapist within 48
hours you'll also get 10 off your first
month by clicking the link in the
description down below that's better
help help dot com slash cosmic
yeah um
i just remember the reaction when
the audience saw black bolt
die
it's just out of left field
yeah and like the whole like no mouth
thing is very horror us it's like you
know like yeah people getting their
mouths so shut you know that's a very
horror type of thing to do um so i guess
appropriate is the right word was it
appropriate well because it's not like
it's marvel doesn't have a set of rules
they have to follow not at all right
but i think fans perceive marvel a
certain way and i think this might have
been outside of that realm of perception
for a lot of people
and that could throw some people off but
going back to the main point it didn't
throw me off i actually thought it kind
of added to it because this is a movie
about witchcraft and magic and the
occult and there's demons and uh i think
it you know in the comics you know
strange fights with mephisto you get a
lot he gets locked in the hell dimension
like there's a lot of dark stuff that
goes down in the comics and at the end
of the day that you know marvel comics
marvel studios their adaptation
adaptations of the comics it's like
that's that happened then and it's
happening now and it's hitting a lot of
fans i think in a really good way and i
think it's really different pace that
marvel
took here i think it's good because it's
not all the same which i think some
people might get tired of eventually and
maybe some people already have gotten
tired of it
already the same kind of superhero thing
over and over again so well that's the
exact question right is
you're the cosmic wonder you're a
million subscribers almost on youtube
i'll just keep saying and plugging you
as much as possible in your own video
but
you know
and understand and love marvel as a fan
and as a critic
yes how many times can you watch the
same movie over and over again before
you need to see black bolt's mouth
disappear and him brad brain pull out
like that's a genuine question so marvel
isn't for kids obviously they they try
to have
a
genre there's a big message for
everybody right
but at the end of the day marvel has to
evolve and that's exactly what we're
saying like was it appropriate that's a
weird word
but was it yeah was it necessary and i
think the answer is 100 yes so we're
seeing that with moon knight we're
seeing that with one division we're
seeing that now yeah more so with doctor
strange the multiverse of madness and
personally as a fan of marvel
and a fan of horror i was extremely
impressed with the way that they made
that happen
yeah i was as well um
the whole
illuminati scene for me
that in its own
was a big i think different direction
than marvel's ever really been a
thousand um
just the way they died
but it's also funny let's talk about the
illuminati scene because i just watched
again like literally got out like an
hour ago
and i just find it so funny the
arrogance of the illuminati yeah very
like they made the avengers are are
historically both in the comics and in
the mcu extremely arrogant right and
they just took the cake they said for
real
like captain marvel variant right maria
rambo is like oh we can handle your
little witch it's like
it's like you know what i felt like i
felt like it was like moon night episode
three or four or whatever it was where
the gods are they're just kind of like
yeah they don't listen to the country
it was almost the exact same you're the
problem we can handle it dr strange
you're the problem
what's that oh hera wants to release on
it haro are you doing this no okay
not even just like a little bit of and
they know though it's funny because
you're like oh we can handle like the
dream walking right you can handle your
witch and it's just kind of like do you
know like who this cartwitch is you know
the power of the scarlet witch it's like
yeah you guys are all sitting there high
and mighty in your chairs and your nice
little chamber of the baxter building
john since you're fantastic loved it so
amazing oh man um
but yeah no the arrogance is ultimately
what led to them
dying right
and is it sad yes but that's also part
of the wonder of the multiverse you know
somewhere out there and i'm not going to
say in our mcu exists another john
krasinski mr fantastic it might be in
ours right but somewhere out there
exists another so we may not have seen
the end of him which i know is what most
people probably out of all those cameos
was most excited to see right
we're hoping right that was a great
cameo that was something
that
it's like you know disney cast um
rosario dawson
as ahsoka because of the fan castings
for her and you have to think this
probably is something similar to that
it's got to be like somewhat similar
right exactly and it's just kind of like
maybe john was already on their mind and
then
all this fan art and stuff starts coming
out and they're just like hey look at
that yeah let's talk to john about mr
fantastic i hope he sticks around
and he's the main mcu i
i will say um we're kind of jumping all
over the place but we will do that uh i
will say i was very disappointed with
the second post credit scene i feel like
it was very much a waste
nothing against bruce campbell but um
that little pun it's it's over like uh
you know what i would have rather seen
deadpool or yeah or dr strange just was
like walking down the street and he sees
a reed richards who hasn't gone through
anything yet yeah right isn't mr
fantastic just a scientist or a sign
baxter building
just a little nod towards because we
have a fantastic four movie coming like
we just lost the director for it but we
still have it
so i would have liked to seen a little
little hint towards that rather than
bruce campbell just doing a joke i mean
he got his little carry on the movie
doctor strange made him punch himself
we didn't need to see three weeks later
would have stopped but no that wasn't
great
yeah but so here's one thing i do want
to address because i think
i think a lot of us went in with certain
expectations for cameos
and
multiversal
madness now i do think
that this movie was madness but i
actually think the madness was misplaced
i think we thought the madness was
coming from multiversal hopping
and a bunch of different characters kind
of teaming up and going through the
multiverse together right yeah whereas
the madness in this film was actually
in wanda
and the things that doctor strange ended
up doing to try and defeat her yeah i
agree with that what do you think no i
completely agree with that and you know
there's a massive online debate and it's
part of the new world you know
an expectations versus reality we talk
about this stuff it's not just us
everybody fans who don't have youtube
channels post on twitter they're fan art
and things they want things to expect
do we allow that to
[Music]
one dictate what marvel wants to do and
two set our desires and expectations and
and i personally don't have an issue
separating the two and you can talk
about spider-man no way home you and i
talked about prior to the movie
releasing if three spider-man aren't in
there does it ruin the film
and i said honestly no
it was super cool and enhanced that they
were in there but my movie experience
wouldn't have been ruined if they
weren't there because it's spider-man
it's it's continuation of the mcu which
is just an absolute treat every time we
get a new project but that's something
that fans are gonna have to decide on
their own
was it different than what we thought
exactly exactly how you light it up like
oh a multiversal avengers kind of people
from every reality
grouping together to go and fight wanda
cause that's the only way we can band
together we can protect our universes
separately together right and that
wasn't the case but
i mean we're not always going to know
what marvel's doing and i think kevin
fighting now more than ever
following the no way home debacle is
trying to keep us on our toes
yeah um
i agree but disagree because i think if
i went to no way home and i didn't see
the other two i would have been
disappointed and it would have taken
away from the experience for me not to
say i would have rated the movie bad or
anything like that
but to agree with you on this i was
expecting a lot more but it did not take
away from the movie for me at all or the
experience it didn't take away from me i
thought
actually after watching it it was better
they kept it kind of focused
right focused because
really at the end it did come down to
like doctor strange and
right
um great introduction
uh zoji gomez she's awesome friend of
both of ours and uh she crushed america
gomez
that wrong
america chavez america governs work
she's she's basically the character now
that's her last name in real life uh
yeah no she she crushed the role of
america chavez and benedict wong of
course always wong is uh is awesome um i
glad they kept it to kind of all of that
they had a few side characters and stuff
and i'm glad they kept it kind of simple
because i heard
that
the test screenings for the original
script and movie how they did everything
was kind of a mess and people were
confused
and i think that's when they went back
and they were like let's just let's keep
it kind of simple now what i thought was
gonna happen
was not necessarily like people from
each universe kind of going together and
like going with strange and like
following him and like let's all group
against her i didn't think that was
gonna happen what i thought was gonna
happen was they were just gonna be
traveling throughout different universes
and in those universes they would see
random variants of random people that's
what i thought right
going on tour and oh here's iron man
it's like quick little cameos right
there's like walking down the street
and
maybe you see you know the avengers
tower maybe you see an iron man fly by
right but it's uh it would have been
cruz it would have been cool to explore
without any actual effect to the movie
the multiverse like you're saying like
let's let's see what's in this universe
oh look right exactly but it doesn't
change what happens it's just no no no
no it doesn't a real cameo
and they kept it simple because
so like when america and doctor strange
fly through
yeah i don't know like 10 well you know
like 10 different universes in that one
part before they get to the illuminati
multiverse uh universe they
they go through a lot and in my mind i'm
like well you could have stopped in one
and been like
what universe is this and then you see
people right and then it's like okay
well we need to get out of here
doctor strange does some
demon spell to scare america's office so
she could open a portal that was that's
all i did like something like that right
yeah um
that's just that's what i thought was
gonna happen so i wasn't i wasn't
necessarily even expecting like an
avengers in-game team-up
or infinity war team up because i just
thought we were just gonna randomly see
them right so it didn't really take away
from my experience i would have loved
more multiverse aspects to it
or i shouldn't say that because there's
a lot of multiversal aspects to it i
would have loved more multiversal travel
it's what i would like no i agree the
multiverse was definitely i mean they
gave us some rules to explain some
consequences which is really something i
if you had to ask me my number one thing
out of the game
that was what i wanted i want direction
yeah i want direction i want to know the
multiverse isn't going anywhere right
that's what we've learned it's going
yeah it's the multiverse saga we just
left the infinity saga welcome to the
multiverse saga that's what we learned
in doctor strange and that's what my
number one hit list what do i want to
see other than deadpool and we can rage
about that in a second
was we will what was was what is what
the heck is the deal with the multiverse
now we have kevin feige saying you know
what it was actually loki's fault you
have america chavez explaining the rules
you have some people from different
universes like reed richards saying what
happens when you mess with a multiverse
that was a huge home run for marvel in
in getting a grasp on what its plan is
for the future
well it's funny because michael waldron
the writer of loki and dr strange
multiverse of madness actually recently
came out and said he regretted defining
the rules so much in loki because they
have to stick to those rules
so it's kind of like i get it as a
writer i get it right as a writer yes
but as a fan it's like no we need it to
be kind of defined so we're not super
confused all the time well not even just
snakes
exactly you don't want it to be
cheap
you yeah there there is a certain
we'll use cheap
i'm gonna say easy way out
there is something of an easy way out
an ease to the multiversal side of it
you can do anything right anything and
it's absolutely so then so then does it
really matter exactly right you know um
but i think
this movie handled that very very well i
agree um one thing i loved about the
movie
non-stop action like from the get
defender strange
yeah defender strange in america just
coming out
and
doctor strange tries to kill her and
that doesn't work out for him
no but it's okay because his corpse is
then later used
did not see that coming yeah right that
was a a very
that was very sam raimi with the arm
coming out
uh i called him today i was like look
it's frank and strange is what i
it's like the turtle
but there were so many cool things to
this and i think it was actually handled
very very well and i think you could see
the marvel
side and sam raimi site at each of it
like when they fight
we don't have a name whether it was
schumacher or gargantos or whatever the
heck it was right we don't have a name
for it
they're kind of the same thing in the
way that they were used
yeah
um
it was like the way it died sticking you
know
what was it a light post i think it was
a light post
right and then pulling it out in the eye
you see the eye come out and everything
like that like that's very like the
fight all was very marvel and then the
the way they killed it was very samurai
me right right and that's awesome and
that is the slow transition that we need
to see every movie needs to be its own
project and i think that this the theme
of season season four of phase four
really is kind of okay let's create some
more individual projects yeah yeah moon
knight
a glorious project epic
completely unrelated to anything so far
and that's completely fine
yeah and that's what they're trying to
do
yeah i agree i think they're going in
different directions
and i think it comes down to like
they're really
trying to their best abilities because
obviously there still has to be
you know some unison and some
connectivity in the mcu because it is
the you know mcu but they're really
trying to give the directors kind of the
freedom to make their own films like
right hey
you're directing a marvel movie
realize it's amazing there are some
rules here right
you know there are things that come with
the marvel movies but
you as a director we love which is why
we're hiring you put your spin on it
right right make it make it yours
and kevin foggy's watching the new in
the heart the entire time and if he
doesn't like it he's gonna tell him you
know like and that's just you know
that's just kevin feige being great at
what he does and that's what we're gonna
that's what i expect from now on is you
know
different projects with the touch of
kevin
right i'm still thinking of my rating
for the film right because i think
everything i saw i i i enjoyed let's do
this for what did you not enjoy
what would you say you would have done
warren would have done differently what
do you think the fans might have wanted
differently let's talk about i mean i
just went on my rant about more
multiversal travel okay i would i would
have done that and i would have made it
longer and i know there are scenes that
were cut
but i would have made it longer and
developed wanda just a little bit more
in the beginning but
but at the same time i actually love how
it just started off and just went for it
wasn't expected right so maybe some type
of
scene
somewhere
after wanda attacks everybody and
american them leave like maybe somewhere
there
where like wanda's explaining to wang
what she went through
after
west view you know after dialogue
and then wang is sitting there going
like wanda this isn't you the dark hold
is corrupting you and wanda just sits
there and goes
i don't care yeah i want my kids back i
could have had something like that yeah
that would be cool
yeah and i i feel like it was i actually
love the pacing of it because it's so
exciting
but it lacks
deep emotional connection
that's what it lacks that's what i think
it lacks
there's some really good moments
uh at the very end where america chavez
is you know i'm glad i you know came to
universe and he's like so my kid so my
great moment she's becoming you know
trying to become a master of the mystic
arts great moment
but uh
the scene that i thought was rushed
was
when he possessed the dead strange
and it went up to her
and you know
they they're having like this touching
moment
where he's like
i i'm here to tell you to believe in
yourself which is a great moment but i'm
like i feel like i needed more before
you led to this big connectivity between
the two of you a big emotional moment
finale thing that causes you to awaken
your powers and have control over them
because everything was like so
fast-paced they're running most of the
time together like that's a good
majority of their time they're literally
running away that's good that's a fair
analysis of that right and then the
other times they're locked inside of
these chambers which they're not really
talking they're just like
talking to christine most of the time
and he leaves and she talks to christine
and
yeah i mean they have that scene in the
beginning where she kind of explains
everything and that's not you know i
would only i would say that they do have
that scene where they see the past
but even
even that's like very individual
like doctor strange is like okay i see
your past like
you're hurt because you think you killed
your your moms and then you know she's
like oh christine blah blah blah you
blew it in your universe as well like my
doctor strange blew it too so
everybody's dr strange i know right and
one of my favorite lines is i love you
at every universe
so that's a great line i tweeted it out
today and then the ladies people said it
was a spoiler like you don't even know
what it's yeah if you don't know you
don't know and if you do know it's not a
spoiler
yeah shut up anyways
i would say
i i yeah
anyways yeah to finish my rant uh i
could have used a little more in-depth
emotionality
that emotional grab and that's something
that marvel builds over time i think
that's always something maybe they've
struggled with but they do the funny
jokes and and they do grab on
eventually like with iron man it's a
super emotional scene but that took 23
movies to get to that you know
um it's marvel's not a drama it's an
action comedy and and it's hard to get
that i think for them every time moon
knight they did a good job everybody i
think had a com an emotional connection
to stephen
and wanted for him to be happy so
hopefully they can develop that more i
think my biggest complaint and i say
this as a marvel fan like it's not
expected is the ending and specifically
i mean just they left so much unanswered
which is what they do and i know it
keeps you wanting more but i would have
liked to know you know
if you're not dead on screen you're not
dead right like
pretty much and ana's not dead right i
would have liked maybe one of the post
credit scenes could have been her arm
moving or something right she's not dead
we'll be honest so if you look
i caught it the first time and i made
sure to watch for it the second time as
like she brings everything down and it
kind of shows it fall on her but then it
shows like the whole
structure falling
and as it falls there's a
huge blast of
red light
and i'm like okay i want to left like to
me
if she doesn't die on screen and most of
the time even then still
you're just not dead well that's the
thing right is you know there's rumors
of like oh marvel just signed another
multi-deal contract with her blah blah
blah
and then i see that red blast i'm just
kidding and then and of course it's
because i didn't see her die and if i
don't see her die
she's not we watched the illuminati die
they're dead i watched
those are dead characters from universe
813 or whatever it was
exactly they're gone
and yeah so
i didn't see one to die and i saw a
burst of red light which was clearly her
magic
you can see it very clearly next time
you guys watch it look for it to me
that's probably her escaping her doing
something or it could you know she
destroyed the dark hole in each universe
which i like how
that's another that's another qualm i
have that was where i was headed next
how did you do that so that could have
been the magic like going out but like i
don't absorb this she had a literally
universe ambiguously something like that
happened yeah because she literally had
the dream walk to go into a different
universe she couldn't even she didn't
even have the ability to go to other
universes and i actually stated that in
one of my you know videos last week i
said i don't think wanda even with the
dark code has the ability to travel the
multiverse so the whole oh every dark
hole has now been destroyed it's like
how interesting that's another one
though like these open-ended question
and then the whole you know doctor
strange
3i thing
i think to the layman marvel fan that's
going to come off as kind of weird and
and and hard to explain
and
almost maybe even unnecessary for the
ending and then just to build right off
of what you were saying for the whole
ending you know doctor strange does this
super evil you can't go and possess a
dead person you're using the dark hole
all this stuff right he gets there and
does
almost nothing
yeah i mean he he does a really cool
demon cape thing and it's visually
pleasing either but america chavez was
it was super cool but he broke all these
forbidden rules and gave himself a third
eye which we don't know what the
consequences are of
right for
almost nothing
yeah which for me so the ending scene
may be a little rushed i would say and i
don't know what they cut they cut maybe
almost 30 minutes out of the movie from
what we've been hearing yeah yeah so i
don't know what ultimately was changed
but that is something that i would say
could have used a little bit a little
more time was that whole ending and
maybe an explanation of where are we
now because this was you know phase
four's big pivot that's what i'm calling
it the biggest pivot in marvel studios
history that's my quote use it on a
trailer if you want
um i allow it
um
but i would have liked just a little bit
more of that last foot stepping over to
be like okay this is what this means
here here we go move on
yeah and i think they did that on
purpose i think they left it open
exactly right you know now to me
the ending was really about
the scarlet witch truly is the most
strongest being in the multiverse you
can't stop there is no
debate
right that and that's and the ending to
me was a statement of that no matter
what strange did he couldn't stop her
even america chavez
all of a sudden gets like control over
her powers and it's really funny because
she's like uh-huh and one is like
and she hits her a few times and then
one is like okay like cool cool little
kid you're cool you're punching me with
a star good job like right but have you
seen what i've done like
and so she's like
i can't beat you america chavez says
that and i and i think that's like the
whole entire thing is like
she had to beat herself
right
and um i was
i was worried about it
i was worried about that before i saw
the movie i was like is that gonna be a
good enough ending
right like she just comes to terms
with it but i think the way they did it
with like
the other wanda
like kind of not being strong enough but
the kids are going get away from my mom
you're a witch you're a witch like i
i think that was handled
very well actually they did it the best
they could with that execution right
exactly
and i like that they did it because the
more i think about it i go yeah because
that is that really is what the ending's
about there's no one stronger than the
scarlet witch so you're not going to be
able to stop her so you you can't have
an ending where somebody stops her
so to me i'm like that's fine because
that solidifies the fact that
she is the strongest being in the
multiverse
yeah i don't think there's any questions
about that at all and and that's partly
also why i just
you couldn't convince me she's gone you
know kevin feige can walk at my front
door and be like nope she's dead i don't
i don't believe you i'm sorry if i get
you something don't you lie to me
but it's true right there's just she's a
beloved character i can't i've gotten
crap for the last eight months on my
channel i'm sure you the same because
everybody
she's going to be the bad guy how dare
you
she's the bad guy let's be honest
doesn't make her a bad guy
but she's the bad guy i know they
imagine c'thun
and um they mentioned his existence and
he wasn't pulling the strings she made
every single decision she wanted to make
because she wanted to be a mom and she
ultimately made the decision to be
a good mom and let her kids have her
real mom but
she's a bad guy she's a bad guy he has a
redeemable plot where she can come back
and try to get herself on the lunch box
in her solo film or in one division two
and i hope she does see her ending happy
ending and i do think we'll be seeing
her again
oh i do too actually one thing i really
want because you're i think like
what are the repercussions because there
there weren't really any repercussions
to our main universe like nothing really
happened you know no
not like nothing about when gone i guess
yeah right that might have some
percussion but um
here's what i want
i want
reed richard said he has kids and
franklin richards is you know his son
who goes on to become an omega level
mutant who could literally create
universes like just with his hands i
want this kid to grow up so pissed off
at the scarlet witch that would be cool
and eventually try to do something about
that would be cool right that's what i
do that would be really cool actually
right because franklin richards i
you can correct me if i'm wrong your
mutant expertise is way better than mine
but is the most powerful mutant
yeah it's really uh
him or magneto right might be in a man
he's strong on the magneto it might be
an opinion
that's debatable but he is i mean he is
one of the strongest if not the
strongest mutant out there i mean he
literally uses galactus as a puppet
right he's got some power he resurrects
galactus actually if i didn't recall
correctly from the comics and marvel
doesn't like anything on accident
right so the mention of your kids was
for something is their mother still
alive like okay sue storm and your kids
right it's like which that was cold and
we all know that it is terrifying
i know right
so
i would like it you know frank lunch is
going to become one of the most powerful
mutants ever he's going to figure out
the multiverse i'm sure since he can
literally create universes you know
pot these with his freaking hands right
so i'm
i'm hoping that there is somewhat of a
repercussion of that and that's a cool
idea
because mordo is still alive
right that's very intentional as well
mordo's not dead marta's still alive so
i'm wondering what happens there
right
and maybe franklin richards gets a
little
you know
grows up his whole entire life super
pissed off i will find this witch right
exactly so
who knows that's what i hope happened
that's crazy
yeah that's what i really hope happened
so yeah there's just
there's a ton of good to the movie i
just
wanted
i want my extra 30 minutes that were cut
i want the 30 minutes that were cut i
agree
and i
i watched it again
and i think i stand firm with my 8 out
of 10.
i think that's where 8 out of ten that's
what i think yeah i think this falls
right below shang chi for me is this an
assumption that
see i always struggle with movie ratings
endgame is a 10. infinity war is a 10.
yep yep right i feel like we need to
make our own rating for marvel movies
because what is the only other thing you
can can compare a marvel movie to is a
marvel movie
i feel like you can't really like oh
let's compare this to shawshank
redemption like it just doesn't really
break
like
marvel movies exist on their own level
they're their own thing they just
absolutely destroy the box office so i
like that you were saying like it's just
below chongqi
yeah because it kind of helps kind of
gauge like this isn't better than
infinity war this isn't better than any
game but is it better than black widow
like
a lot right like
that much better than black widow right
this movie yeah
sits up
with the best team-up movies with so it
does with no it does original avengers
movie it is up there it's somewhere in
between that somewhere underneath
infinity war and in game obviously
it's the best project to face for in my
opinion oh for sure
to me it's like i it's always a infinity
war and in game for me and yes affinity
war infinity wars first for me
uh end game ragnarok shangchi
and either this or civil war for fifth
was that five yeah
let's see so
it's definitely top tier marble it's top
tier mark and that is i think the big
question is oh what do you rate it if we
have five shelves it's on the top shelf
or right below
you would say well no because the okay
your shelves don't necessarily mean five
movies but yes no five shelves yeah like
shelves right here
absolutely black widow
yeah it's definitely in the top shelf uh
category yeah no i mean
it's a
superior marvel movie and i think just
because of the innovativeness yeah
that's a big part of going this horror
route and a little bit more roger than
we're used to it also you know increases
the value
no it does and it makes it valuable in
the sense that it is unique and it does
give us a little little glass of what's
to come maybe with the midnight suns
hopefully yeah no you got a deadpool
movie coming there is nothing that was
in the first two deadpool movies that we
didn't see in doctor strange the
multiverse of man yeah they 100 can do
any of that except there wasn't swearing
that's up to them if they want to add
swearing but all of that getting sliced
in half and your mouth blowing up and
right that's all the kind of gore that
deadpool does and that's completely on
the table now even my brother who was
watching it with me and my uncle
um
they were like oh my gosh they were like
shocked and i was like
you know and i was even like
i was like because i i don't do that
stuff so i'm like do i like just like
turn my head real quick but i'm like no
i'll watch it again i'm just like i'm
gonna have to figure it's my job yeah
i'm just like but yeah no you you heard
a audible like oh like they're in the
audience then they do so yeah
oh sorry
no i was just gonna say so yeah very
very like bright future for the darker
side of the mcu with the midnight sun's
deadpool all that stuff blade
blades should have a ton of sliced in
half they should also have a few of
those
yeah yeah
i would just say the defining element of
horror
you know is discomfort it's not gore
it's not
you know
it's
discomfort and
it was uncomfortable because of the
setting because of the past of marvel
the expectation
sam raimi just pushed those limits far
enough that you're kind of queasy you're
kind of like yeah this was unexpected
from this genre of movie so so top notch
and congrats for that big time 10 i
could have expected
yeah i agree but i could have done it
without
freaking patrick stewart died
okay that's unacceptable i'm done with
that
no more that is the end of it
oh yeah no
and because i was uneasy which i
which i guess i guess was the goal right
yeah right again i'm not a not a horror
fan i uh i like my superhero movies
happy endings and shawarma at the end
let's go right yeah where there was no
shawarma in this one
uh
so yeah but i i stick to my eight out of
ten i think it was a great movie um i
just wish it was
longer to add more a little bit more
depth like that character connection you
were talking about i think was probably
one of the biggest absence is
of the film
yeah do you have a rating or no i think
i give it an eight i think i always
struggle with one through tens you know
me i'm weird about that but i i'll just
say it's on the top shelf i'm gonna say
marvel has five shelves i'm putting it
on the first shelf i don't think it's
the best movie marvel's ever made
definitely the best project of phase
four probably by a lot
and um it's it's set us in a really cool
direction that we were kind of wondering
you know is the multiverse gonna matter
beyond this movie
or is it going to be the thing and it's
the thing it's the thing so it's
something to be excited about because
there is more to explore you wanted more
exploration of the multiverse well it's
coming so
yeah i definitely think so and it looks
like they're uh going to the dark
dimension again next with clea
who you know the comics he marries
eventually so this is going to be
exciting i'm excited for uh
a lot of different things because
they're they're everywhere you got the
guardians and thor and space and then
you've got secret wars it's going to be
in space the marvels well secret wars is
both in space and on earth we believe um
probably more on earth but then the
marvels you know all that cosmic stuff
nova nova
nova yeah a lot of different stuff
coming and so now we're like going into
different realms like dark dimension and
stuff like that so uh and as we saw
there are a lot of different weird
universes out there so maybe they'll
explore some of those weird ones so i
hope so
future's really really bright but let us
know what did you think of multiverse of
madness uh rate it however you please
whether that's one out of ten a plus to
what shell minus
top one shut you know the top shelf the
first shelf or the last shell from the
bottom number five or however you want
to rate it just let us know your
thoughts about what you thought about it
down below your thoughts on what you
thought about it that's a that's a great
quote
let us know what you thought about it
in the comments because uh i want to
know i actually
i i'm curious because i you know you see
that people are like i'm not going to
take my kids to see this i'm like i mean
maybe if they're like five don't take
them right but if they're like like a
ten-year-old yeah
yeah
and it is a pg-13
right yeah it's not like oh this was
made for five-year-olds let's watch
somebody's head get exploded it is made
for 13 year olds and i don't think it's
not girl appropriate
no 13 year olds can see it but i
i don't
consider them kids yeah everyone yeah
they're all anyways
but yeah let us know if you have kids
around
10 would you take them to watch this is
it appropriate i would
i think i would but i don't have but i'm
not a parent
yeah right so but yeah this was uh this
was the start of the first one uh these
should be coming every week
so stay tuned and i hope you enjoyed
this first one i hope you enjoyed dr
strange the multiverse of madness
because i did chris did and i've i've
talked to a lot of people that have so
far so let us know down below don't
forget to subscribe to my channel and of
course chris's channel over at cosmic
culture and i will see you guys next
week
woof
okay bye